RETO MEIER: It's
officially Week 4
of Google Cloud Next
OnAir, which means
we're focusing on security.
I'm Reto Meier, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week 4 is all about
security, meaning
we want to help you
achieve your security
goals while prioritizing
operational simplicity
and keeping costs down.
So we've got sessions on
everything from data protection
to compliance policies to
managing sensitive data.
You can also hear directly from
other Google Cloud customers
sharing their own
security experiences.
One of the best parts of
attending a conference
is learning the
clever and sneaky tips
from some of the people who
actually created the products.
That's why this advanced IM
session is so compelling,
because authentication and
policy management are constant.
So a deep dive into
advanced controls
sounds like a great way to avoid
future policy change conflicts.
My pick for the week is Getting
Started with BeyondCorp,
because I really like it when we
can share the tools that Google
is actually running on.
That's the Google Cloud
origin story after all.
And this session introduces
the BeyondCorp security model
and how shifting your
security protections
from a physical
perimeter-- like, say,
your office building-- to
individual accounts and devices
allows your employees to work
remotely without a VPN, which
may be particularly useful to
you in this nonsense of a year.
Finally, if you're looking
to hone your skills,
be sure to check
out to Cloud Study
Jam, where you can
join other attendees
for guided hands-on labs.
There are several
options this week,
including HTTP Load
Balancer with Cloud Armor
and User Authentication,
Identity-Aware Proxy.
Be sure to register for a study
jam to learn from an expert.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or
tweet us using the hashtag
#GoogleCloudNext.
We'll see you in the cloud.